Before we go, we have a quick pick
from my Little Yellow Book,
and that's a list of things that I love and I wanna share,
and you can also check it out on our website
because I load it up with good stuff every week.
And today, it's Free Rain sparkling water.
That's right.
So many people are drinking fizzy water these days,
and I love this brand, okay?
It's flavored seltzer with really good stuff added.
They've got, check this out,
tart cherry and Siberian ginseng for energy.
Oh, you hear that? I just opened it.
Oh, I heard it.
(audience chuckles)
Okay, yes.
That beautiful?
It's very good.
I kinda wanna mix it with something later tonight.
I'm sure you can!
Blood orange and ginger with ashwagandha for focus.
Ashwa, what?
(audience laughs)
Ross, I'm laser into you.
I am so ashwagandha-ed into you,
I can't even talk about it.
I really taste the ginger.
I love this so much, and.
Yeah, these are good.
Blackberry and passion flower for calm.
Okay, let's chill out.
(audience chuckles)
Oh, girl.
No, these are good.
You know what?
These are unexpected flavors.
Aren't they beautiful?
Mm-hm.
Well, and the good people at Free Rain
are giving away sparkling waters
to all of our VFFs today.
Oh, hey.
So cheers to that,
and I just love getting to share recommendations
and things that I discover in life along the way.
Aren't we all here?
If that was like my job credential, sharer.
Yeah, that's so fun that you can just find things
that you love
and then you can let everybody else know about it.
How do I find your Little Yellow Book?
It's on our website, and I refresh it every week,
and it's just something I...
I love social media in that I think I fell in love with it,
not 'cause I was dying to put myself out there more.
I don't think anyone needed more of me,
but I loved that it was a platform for talking about things
that we were discovering in life.
Yum. I actually knew where I could find it.
I just asked because I wanted them to know. (laughs)
Well, I wanna thank everyone for being here today
and to my wonderful bud, Ross.
Well, thank you for telling me about "Bridgerton".
I'm gonna be watching all weekend long.
Oh, get ready.
Okay, it woke her up.
Let's see what happens to me.
(upbeat music)
♪ Whoa oh oh ♪